today's episode is sponsored by dashlane
you've probably heard of identity
protection password managers and vpns
but do you have them are you using them
well if not
you certainly should be and the best way
to do that is with dashlane which is
a one-stop shop for all of your digital
identity protection needs if your
passwords are the same that's a bad idea
you can use
dashlane's password manager to create
and securely store complex and unique
passwords making it
less likely that your accounts are going
to be compromised they also have a vpn
as part of their service meaning that
you can browse the internet securely and
confidently even on public wi-fi plus
dashlane does what it's always done it
stores your passwords it keeps your
personal data secure it fills all of
those annoying boxes for payment info
and passwords for you
a lot of dashlane is free but there are
some premium upgrades and you can buy
those
if you want but the first 200 people can
enjoy an exclusive 10
off dashlane premium with the discount
code visualpolitik which you can use at
dashlane.com forward
visualpolitik so go protect yourself
right now and
let's get into today's video i regret
the day i said yes to mr trump
i regret all the help and support i gave
him along the way
i am ashamed of my own failings
february 27 2019 michael cohen donald
trump's lawyer and trusted sidekick for
the last decade appeared before the u.s
congress his statement was a bombshell
against the president
cohen accused trump of cooperating with
russia during the election campaign as
well as several tax crimes he also
described
donald trump as a racist a con man and a
cheat
i am ashamed because i know what mr
trump is he is a racist
he is a con man and he is a cheat you
know a little impressed by that frankly
could have he could have gone all out he
only
went about 95 percent instead of a
hundred percent
[Applause]
so davio while michael cohen was talking
about donald trump the president of the
united states himself was
thousands of kilometers away from
washington on a trip in hanoi the
vietnamese capital
to meet with the north korean leader kim
jong-un
in what was the second summit between
the two leaders
but i think having a fake hearing like
that
and having it in the middle of this very
important summit
is really a terrible thing this is a
summit that has been dismissed by
most of the media as a failure and this
leaves us with a big question well was
the hanoi summit really a failure where
exactly did the negotiations between the
united states and
north korea end up let's take a look
[Music]
all right so there are some exceptions
but generally sequels are never as
exciting as the original right
two cruise control well it looks like
something similar happened in hanoi
[Music]
just eight months after the historic
first meeting in singapore donald trump
and kim jong-un they saw
each other again expectations were that
this time a concrete agreement would be
reached with deadlines
goals and objectives however that didn't
happen
the summit ended hastily without any
specific understanding
on the one hand north korea demanded
that all international sanctions be
eliminated in exchange for dismantling
its main nuclear complex
not the only one it has the yeong byong
complex a center dedicated to the
production of plutonium and uranium fuel
for north korea's nuclear weapons
on the one hand the united states
demanded that north korea take the first
step dismantling all of its nuclear
programs production and development
centers including
all the clandestine centers after this
they would contemplate lifting the
international sanctions
[Music]
as you can see their positions weren't
entirely compatible north korea didn't
want to give up its nuclear program and
the united states wasn't willing to make
concessions
at all the dilemma that we were
confronted with
is the north koreans at this point are
unwilling to impose
a complete freeze on their weapons of
mass destruction
programs so to give many many billions
of dollars in sanctions relief
would in effect put us in a position of
subsidizing the ongoing development of
weapons of mass destruction in north
korea
a state department official speaking to
the washington post but don't think this
came as a surprise it's true donald
trump did seem very upbeat thinking that
in exchange for guaranteeing a splendid
future for north korea with
investments and economic development
he'd managed to convince kim jong-un
to change his ways well check this out
our united states team has arrived in
north korea to make arrangements for the
summit between kim jong-un
and myself i truly believe north korea
has
brilliant potential and will be a great
economic and financial nation one day
kim jong-un agrees with me on this it
will happen
donald trump but the truth is that his
team was much
less optimistic north korea will seek to
retain
its wmd capabilities and is unlikely to
completely
give up its nuclear weapons and
production capabilities
because its leaders ultimately view
nuclear weapons as critical to
regime survival both secretary of state
mike pompeo and national security
adviser john bolton had expressed their
doubts about being able to reach an
agreement
[Music]
the fact is that this is what every
media source has been told and is the
reason
why the summit was considered a true
failure but hold on a second because the
question we want to answer is well was
it really
a failure well yeah it kind of was but
also no
[Applause]
dear viewer let's be upfront about this
on visualpolitik we don't exactly
sympathize with donald trump but we
always want to be objective which
is not the same as being neutral so we
believe that we can give you
three reasons why the summit unlike what
most of the media have said
wasn't an absolute failure so listen up
[Music]
objective vietnam
although it often goes unnoticed with
more than 90 million inhabitants vietnam
has not only become one of the fastest
growing economies in the world in the
last three decades but
it's also become increasingly important
to the united states
yes it may be surprising but these two
countries that less than half a century
ago were protagonists of one of the
longest and harshest wars in history are
now two
significant economic and political
[Music]
partners
you want more proof of this tight
relationship in march of 2018 the
aircraft carrier uss carl vinson set
sail for four days in da nang it was the
first visit to vietnam by a u.s military
ship since the end of the war in 1975.
[Music]
the point is that donald trump's visit
didn't have only one goal but
rather two allow me to explain
[Music]
the white house took advantage of this
trip to strengthen its ties with the
vietnamese government
trump met both the president and the
prime minister and presided over a
symbolic act in which several vietnamese
airlines commissioned more than 20
billion dollars to purchase aircraft and
services from american companies in
particular boeing in addition they
mapped out a free trade agreement and
the sale of billions of dollars of
military equipment
[Music]
that's because the united states wants
to turn vietnam into one of its most
important partners
in this area of the world both
politically and economically
why well because vietnam is growing by
leaps and bounds
further it's very open to trade it's got
unfriendly relations with china and its
workforce
has very low labor costs in other words
it's a perfect country to flood with
dollars
although i'm not sure how trump's going
to cope with the fact that the united
states has a trade deficit with vietnam
of almost 40 billion dollars
for its part vietnam aims to receive all
of those dollars to accelerate its
development
its autonomy from china and its
leadership in southeast asia
hanoi is desperate for a better
relationship with washington
and would like a free trade agreement
with the trump administration to ensure
it is not entirely dependent on chinese
markets
and consumers vietnam also would love to
purchase
large amounts of advanced us military
equipment harry j
kazianis director of korean studies at
the center for the national interest
well what better way than giving vietnam
the prominence and political influence
of hosting a summit of this type and if
they also use it to strengthen ties well
that's even better wouldn't you agree
well that's precisely what happened
[Music]
cards on the table
in a visualpolitik video about the
singapore summit we explained how north
korea's concept of what denuclearizing
the korean peninsula means and how it's
very different from what the rest of the
world understands
[Music]
north korea has no intention of giving
up its nuclear weapons at least
not in such a straightforward way
it'll probably come as no surprise when
i say that the north korean regime is a
cruel dictatorship with an absolutely
abominable track record when it comes to
human rights
isolated from the rest of the world and
ruled with an iron fist by three
generations of the family of the current
leader kim jong-un
we're talking about a country where
citizens can be sent to prison for
simply watching
reading or listening to international
media it's a country where any dissent
or disagreement about the government can
lead to brutal re-education
and forced labor camps it's a country
with a state that
exploits its own people by making them
work in semi-slavery conditions
[Music]
while despite all of this donald trump's
desire to push through his precious
agreement along with his predilection
for dictators and authoritarian
positions
glossed over the true nature of the
policies of pyongyang
everyone's looking out for their own
interests no one's looking out for the
interests of north korea's
citizens brad adams asia director of
human rights watch
be very surprised very smart very good
negotiator
really he's got a great personality he's
a you know
funny guy he's a very smart guy he's a
great negotiator
he loves his people not that i'm
surprised by that but he loves his
people
don't let anyone think anything
different he speaks and his people sit
up at attention i want my people to do
the same
[Music]
well thanks to this failed summit the
cards have remained on the table
kim jong-un's regime has no intention of
giving up its power or its nuclear
weapons and
let's make this clear forcing north
korea to acknowledge this dance publicly
actually
strengthens the united states for any
future negotiations
now any expectations for subsequent
agreements have dropped
and that was needed actually it was a
very productive two days but
sometimes you have to walk washington
has gained the upper hand in the
negotiations which they will continue to
flex because they know north korea
desperately needs to overcome its
sanctions
now this all leads us to our third point
the reforms everything depends on the
reforms
folks just 30 years ago vietnam was in
an even worse situation than north korea
the country was
shattered by wars and suffering from a
blockade from china the united states
europe and even its southeast asian
neighbors its economy it was
literally sunk leaving about 70 of its
inhabitants to live in extreme
poverty since then things they've
changed
a lot
[Music]
today only around three percent of
vietnam's population lives in extreme
poverty that's a massive reduction
seventy percent to three percent well
the fact is that vietnam unilaterally
implemented its own reform plan
known as the doi moy they started doing
this even before they reconciled with
the international community
that is they were doing this while they
were suffering a blockade from the
united states
and what could be a better example for
north korea what better action to
involve vietnam in this process and set
it up as an example it's a great way to
let pyongyang know
what they could achieve the success of
the vietnamese economy
is due to its decision to normalize
relations with the united states in
1995.
i would say to our north korean friends
as long as they have a conflict with the
united states
they will not be able to develop their
economy properly major general
win levon kwang former director of the
institute of strategic studies at the
vietnamese ministry of public security
we've told you in several videos which
we'll link to in the description that
kim jong-un
seems determined to promote economic
reforms and open north korea well what
better way to persuade him than by
showing him the results
hand no revolutionary tasks stand before
us other than the improvement of the
economy and
people's daily lives kim jong-un folks
the united states it seems to know that
the north korean problem will only be
solved with a new strategy that focuses
more on trade than on weapons maybe the
summit didn't have the expected result
but does that mean it was a failure the
answer is not so clear
at first glance especially if we
consider the white house's new strategy
we are not going to invade north korea
we are not
seeking to topple the north korean
regime we are ready
for a different future it's bigger than
denuclearization
i'm absolutely convinced and more
importantly the president of the united
states
is convinced that it's time to move past
70 years of war and hostility on the
korean peninsula there is no reason for
this conflict to persist
any longer stephen r began the u.s
special representative for north korea
so what do you think do you support the
trump administration's strategy towards
north korea well leave your answer in
the comments below as well as in this
survey and i really hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit that like
button
if you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos also please do
check out our friends at reconsider
media they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine also this
video is brought to you by
dashlane for that special discount
please do check them out through the
description
below and as always i'll see you next
time
you're very surprised very smart very
good negotiator
really he's got a great personality he's
a you know
funny guy he's a very smart guy he's a
great negotiator
he loves his people not that i'm
surprised by that but he loves his
people
don't let anyone think anything
different he speaks and his people sit
up in attention i want my people to do
the same